[Music]
so pens provides a way to easily share
things either across projects or across
people what ends up happening oftentimes
in in data science work
we have some asset and maybe it's
data or it's a model or some other our
object
and we either
need to
um
reuse this asset
later on downstream or across different
projects or we might need to share it
with different members of our team you
know we say anything that can be
serializable in our
so think about like how you might stick
something
on a cork board so you can keep it handy
right or you know you'd stick a flyer on
a community bulletin board at the
grocery store right so that other people
can see it um and so the pens package
pins objects to what's called a board
this is analogous to this cork board um
idea and so this board um is this place
where files are written and they're read
from um examples of boards are things
like you can have a board that's s3
storage um
shared folders like network drives or
dropbox um you can have um your rcu
connect be a board
um a sharepoint site be a board really
it's just it's just a file store a file
share nothing magical about that it's
just pins has a nomenclature and a way
of organizing things in this place on
the board so that you can interact with
them
through the package
okay so what i'm hearing is i can pin
all kinds of things
in all kinds of locations
yes
it works nicely with connect um but
there's nothing specifically implemented
in pens
for connect
um
there
the the things that connect does
to make life for pens a little bit
better
connect will give you access to the same
sharing content sharing settings
that you have for any piece of content
on connect so i can you know put my pin
on connect and i can specify who
should be able to access it
and share it um and then and then pins
um
pins does have a nice preview of the um
pinned object i like that feature but
that's that's connect that's that's a
connect implementation for how it reads
pins nothing specific in the pins
package itself
so if i work by myself either in a what
for whatever reason i am a team of one
how might i use pins a lot comes down to
um what are your pain points
and
like what do you have available to you
already
for
storing data sharing data accessing data
downstream things like that
all right um so
do you
in your team of one
do you need to reuse something in other
work
right do you have like a reference table
or you know some kind of other
information that multiple projects are
going to use you might need to come back
to this
pinch could be a pretty good use case
for that right um or you know do you
do you just not have a convenient place
to
put things no pins comes in and gets to
be really helpful
when you just maybe don't have another
place to store data sometimes um
you know teams that don't have ready
access to a database um you know find
pins to be pretty helpful because it
kind of makes them self-sufficient
they can be more autonomous in this way
you don't have the mechanism to you know
either get a hold of a database or have
one set up or even like the data that
you're working with isn't
um
isn't
a sorry word worthy of being in a
database right um then then
you can use a pen as a place to i'm
going to have this um
nice location where it's organized it's
versioned um i can work through cached
versions of it as well so things go
faster um and it it helps to alleviate
other pain points if you have places
like
if if putting things in dropbox or on
github or if those things are working
for you already then you know you don't
need to bring this tool into your
toolbox per se sort of like what pain
points do you have what needs to you
maybe have in terms of being able to
track versions um or share things more
readily
that was part of my entry point for pins
too is working with excel files just
like that right and and what do you do
when you've got this excel file in your
workflow
at some point you're going to get
another version of it right
and either on the file server where this
where the file is stored or in your code
every time there's a new version you're
going to go in there and rename it right
and so
you're it's going to be final version
one or latest copy or whatever right
final final final final
right with your initials on the end and
so somewhere along the line you're going
to be putting some kind of hacked
versioning
nomenclature on it and
there's this introducing possibility for
error of course right um
how many times you've like gone in and
you've run your whole analysis and
realize oh i forgot to change the
read underscore csv to the latest
version right or you know or do you
actually have um
more rigor like going to the file server
and
changing the file name so that the
latest version is always called whatever
you know data.csv and then everything
else is archived in some form or fashion
you're
implementing this like
hacky way of keeping things current um
whereas with pens right you can pin that
csv and
so pins has different options for
versioning but you know fundamentally
you can have pens always pull the latest
version
and so whenever you know your code just
says can read you know
data from my pin board
it's always going to pull the latest
version or if you want to get specific
you can say i'm i want this particular
version
always in each every time so that even
if new versions come online then you're
always referencing the specific one
let's say i'm using dropbox
do i just get one board or can i set up
different boards for different projects
or is it like one board per system like
i get one dropbox board one google drive
board one connect board
yeah it took it took me a while to kind
of get my mind around what's this thing
called a board it it sounds like there's
magic
under the hood or something really
special about boards um
there's there's nothing really super
exciting about boards per se it's a file
path
basically it's a file path so
so i i have um i have on my on my screen
here this is my browser window here
right
i i started a dropbox um
uh location i have a folder called pens
like i manually created this folder
called pens
and so earlier today i just started
pinning stuff but this this is
all that my
board is
my board is a file path that's users
katie dropbox
pins
um you know and this is this is where
i've defined it
this is my board and what happens when
you define a board it just says like
this is where i'm going to go write or
read my files and where they live
um you know and while we're here right
what are these what are these magical
mythical pens look like on the file path
it's not that special
so
it's it's um a hash of the date and the
time in a particular hash for the pen
itself
and two things inside here's an rds file
with my um my classic penguins data and
here's a text file it's just got
metadata included in it
so
you know if
if i wanted to
i could go and just go into my code and
read that rds file manually
now that it's not like once a pen always
a pen it's just a thing it's just a
serializable thing in r but pens is
going to make it easier for me to
find these locations work with them in a
consistent manner pull them in read them
in and kind of interpret and work with
this metadata overall
[Music]
one of the first things that you do with
pins
is define your board right and like i
said your board can be
on connect it can be on s3 it can be
github or or folder url local or
whatever um so in this case just i like
being able to see what we're doing while
we're playing
so i'm creating this board that's just a
folder
um this folder happens to be my dropbox
um path here right
but
i can
to my heart's content let's make another
board
and
um
[Music]
make it versioned we'll talk about that
in a second
old folder
oh my gosh i have to type all this
you know the autocomplete
dropbox this is fabulous
so i've created two different
definitions for my board for my board
okay this one's versioned
this one oh sorry
this one is not version
this one is version it's the same file
path okay i can have multiple boards
right i'm just
describing with each definition of board
i'm just describing where it is how i'm
accessing it
in different characteristics of it so
for example you know these two different
boards regular board and board version
i'm just saying when i'm using this file
path when i'm using this board
either do or don't automatically keep
multiple versions of my pin for me
and so there's different ways you know
for dealing with with versions
um you can define things at this higher
level on the board level and says
anything that i pin to this board i want
it automatically to be versioned
um you know and and for example um if
you're doing a um
our studio connect board by default the
rs connect um board itself is version
equals true just out of the box default
um
but typically typically the version is
false is turned off by default
um
and if so then you can also then do
versioning
at the pen level
and so
you can see down here
as i've defined my pen getting ahead of
ourselves
to find my pen i can specify even if my
board isn't versioned i can make my
specific pin version and then have
different
different iterations of it okay
that's that's really cool
[Music]
caching is another nice feature right
that once you pull once you once you've
got it set up you pulled in your pen
um
there will be a cached version of that
and so
um it will only pull a fresh version
if the data has changed and so it can be
a time saver utilizing that cache
overall
[Music]
are there some limits can i just pin
everything
no
no
that would be irresponsible um
there's you need to think a little bit
about what's appropriate so there's sort
of two elements right
what's appropriate in terms of what are
you trying to pin um is it something
that maybe belongs in a database
um you know don't
don't use pens for
long-term
archival storage of data right things
like your your crown jewel data don't
make that a pen
that needs to go in a database right
there are best practices around data and
databases and backing things up and
access all these things
don't replace your databases with pens a
good practice is to
um
make
dependable objects something that is
reproducible
right don't count on your pen
being your source of truth for all of
eternity make sure it's something that
you can programmatically reproduce
um
pins are often really good with like
ephemeral data
stuff that's just like coming in it's
kind of in the middle of my process i
kind of need to stick this somewhere and
then be done and keep working with it um
ephemeral data is really good really
lightweight data you know look up tables
stuff like that things that make your
life easier it's good to use for a pen
um and then in terms of size
a few hundred megabytes is great um if
it's um really if it's too big for excel
it's too big to pen
um kind of a
don't push it
so we talked about boards already right
boards
it's not magic i think that just as a
file path where am i going
um
and so
in this case let's just use this board
here that is my dropbox location
get rid of this one here
if i'm on the board so first of all i
can just do um a quick query it's like
what's out there so i'm going to do
board and
pins is pipeable
um which is nice so you can work with it
right i typically you know define my
board
as my first step and then pipe that into
all of my different functions so we'll
pipe board into pin list and you can see
here's all of my pens that i have and
this is
mimicking right it's it's bringing in
what you can see here in my file browser
um
there's also if you're not quite sure
what's out there or if you kind of want
to get more information pin search is
nice pin search will search the um the
names and the titles
of your pins um so in this instance i
don't have very many pins so i'm just
going to search for the blank query with
the double quotation marks and it does
present kind of in a nicer format than
just the list that we got in the last
one right you can see a little bit more
information we created and the file size
and whatnot
um and like i said it will search the
name and the title
um so if i'm looking for penguins
i've got two pens right i've got
penguins and i have
not penguins right so searching those
different things um
but this is good for finding things
right um you can also so pins has
metadata associated with them which can
be pretty helpful
um so i've got this pen here it's um not
super exciting but it's just a time
stamp
um but the metadata associated with that
i can see what it is and in this case
when i pinned it you can also include
your own custom
metadata
um so that can be very useful as you're
building out a project or you want to
put specific things into that metadata
there is a place to put that into
into the metadata you can see how i put
that in up here as i wrote this pin
and i just specified the metadata as a
list i love that
and then different versions we've talked
about versions right so i can see what
versions i have
so here in my pens versions for
timestamps i've got five different
versions and
that's just c for sanity
right over here in my actual file
browser
here's my five different versions
and you can see you know i mean it does
get to be um
duplicative right it's just
copy copy copy one after another so it's
not not the smartest package in terms of
file space right this is kind of going
back to this
use pins if it makes your life easier
it's kind of quick and dirty and it's
there to help you help you to kind of
get things done are there more elegant
ways of doing things sure maybe are
there maybe better workflows for
long-term archival data storage
absolutely
but pins is definitely useful in these
use cases
[Music]
so we've talked about the pen read and
its complement um the penrite and the
pen read um functions
there is another set of functions for
pen upload and pen download
and so these these kind of take a little
bit of an abstraction layer further out
um and really this is for being able to
pin
any kind of file
like an r data file for example right so
if you have an r data file again here's
my board my dropbox board
i have this r data file
and what is it right it's just this
collection
of my four different variables and
things that i like to have for breakfast
um so
if i wanted to put this on a board
i'd use the pin upload
function
and pin upload right we can
sort of see what's going to happen over
here i have this i have this over
here right and this is looking familiar
right here's my hash but here's my r
data file itself no magic there right
here's my
metadata and it's just
tidally nested over here in my um in my
file folder um and and and you'll note
here right it's replaced the version
that i had before as opposed to
appending a version because i didn't
tell it i want a versions board
um
and so the complement to pen upload is
pinned download
okay
and what pin download does
is it returns
a path
to the cached file
that it's downloaded right so what does
that look like here's my output
here's where it's living
here's where it's downloaded that file
and cached it
and so i can now right if i want to
bring that object in
pins board
path to cache file right i have my path
and let's just load it
so you can use
pin upload and pin download
to be able to
bring other
objects files things like that into that
structure that pens provides for being
able to read metadata
play with versions call things have
caching things like that
[Music]
it's um one of the legacy functions um
in the api and sort of what what that
means right so the first iteration i
would say of of the pins package had a
different overall format and different
api behind it for doing the read and
write functions and so um in gosh
maybe nine months ago maybe a year ago
um i don't know
pandemic time it doesn't make sense
anymore
a little while ago
a new um a new version a new um api
version of pins came out and it started
with pins version 1.0 we're at 1.01
right now i believe and that um retooled
under the hood the api that was um
calling and writing and interacting with
pen boards
and we also saw some of the older
functions drop off
that being said though
that doesn't mean so google cloud
doesn't mean that that's not going to be
a board in the future um there's
currently an issue right now um on the
repo to
to bring google cloud as one of the
new implementations of the boards and
really it's just a matter of if if
that's something that's useful for folks
um we just need people to go in and put
a plus one um on the issue to help weigh
the priority for developing that
so we've talked about we've talked about
um pinning
pin and data ping data frames things
like that
but pinning models is a really nice
workbook um and all the work that
julia's been doing around vetiver um i
think showcases that really nicely
um
and so
what you can do with the package right
with with with vetiver you can pin
a vetiver model um and then with that
you'll have all of the information
about that model that you need to deploy
it um and call it and work with it and
so then you can you can then um
call that model or different versions of
that model
into
other assets downstream right so a super
simple example of that
um
so earlier today let's see what do i
have i borrowed
some of julia's nice work here um a um a
model that she has just demonstrated
here uh with home prices in sacramento
she's using a random boris model um
and creating this model um
saving it as a vet over model
um and if we do this right let's
actually look at this what this looks
like
all right so what is b b is a ranger
regression
modeling workflow using core features
so with this i'm going to pin this
in this case again i'm going to just pin
it on my dropbox folder
so we'll pin this and
[Music]
where's my model
so i have these different models here
and
now i'm going to use this model so first
of all
one of these workflows that she's
illustrated is to
wrap this model up into an api
so that you can ping it
and query it right so
i'll take this model
and
my background job here
there's functions within the vetiver
package
for creating a vetiver api
um in this case i'm just gonna run this
locally
um i could publish my api i could
publish it somewhere host on connect or
host it in some other place that i have
in my infrastructure for right now i'm
just going to run this locally so i can
hang off of this
and what this looks like
so if we run this
this is just running locally this has a
nice swagger interface so i can
test out and check try my model right so
first i'm going to
um just do a this is just a ping right
and it's just responding with the time
and the date
but if i want to run this locally so i'm
actually going to run this as a
background job
because when this is when this is
running let me run this again
right if this is running it's just
consuming and occupying my console so i
can't interact with it
so
a whole lot of good that does this i'm
gonna run this as a background job
so that i can interact and still play
with my console
so here's my background job
and i'm going to run this
and this is now running so i just go to
a browser
all right let's pull up a browser window
so here i'm in the browser window just
like we had in the preview
but now i have a console window
okay
and so i'm going to use my model less
than pinned
and i'm going to
define an endpoint
my endpoint is this prediction endpoint
here
and i'm going to create some new data
and then predict off that endpoint
and so i just run predictions off of
that pinned model
that i have hosted as and that i have
running as an api in the background
but what's nice is that right in this
model that i'm running
i remember i pulled it from a pen
never pen
i specified the version so say i had a
different version of this model that i
wanted to run
well let's see you know which versions
do i have i've got three different
versions right here
i want to
instead
you know grab this version
so whoops
right if i wanted to use this version
then i would just change here which
which particular version that i'd be
reading in from my pen and serving up
via my api overall
and so this is a nice way that you can
toggle back and forth
and try different versions of your
pinned model
[Music]
you